[Musik]
für den 15
ja
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video
wir sind gerade hier in köln sind in die
innenstadt gefahren hinter dem video ist
noch felix hallo auf jeden fall ich weiß
nicht ob ihr euch noch an die videos
erinnert könnt wo ich so einen automaten
gekauft habe das ist echt cool
angekommen und viele haben gesagt machte
dazu machen ja ich habe mir was cool ist
überlegt und zwar war es wirklich ein
bisschen arbeit ich habe verschiedene
filialen angeschrieben ob man das da
drehen kann und ich habe echt viele
absagen bekommen weil die nicht wollen
dass man irgendwie mit diesen greif
automaten dreht ich habe mir heute als
change überlegt dass ich einfach mal 100
euro abheben
wie also mit felix zusammen wie die in
diesen greif automaten ballern und mal
schauen welche rauskriegen so durfte ich
bin gespannt wie viel man wirklich
kriegt und ich würde sagen wir nehmen
euch einfach mal mit lassen doch nach
oben da bin ich die idee gefällt und im
märz zu automaten sehen wollte
muss das sein weil ich noch echt eine
menge coole ideen was man noch machen
kann
ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt einfach
mal los hey heute das richtige also
heute also hier bis zu 900 euro ab das
müsste dann in diesem laden noch klein
machen und wir müssen das ganze ein
bisschen verdeckt für habe ich auch
schon gesagt weil die das nicht wollen
also deswegen films mit handy und
schauen einfach mal was passiert und wie
viele stofftiere die aus diesem scheiß
auch noch mal rausgehen weil ich ja von
vielen seiten schon gehört dass das halt
wirklich betrug ist und die so ein
bisschen manipuliert sind wir werden
sehen
dann kann ich mich doch dann kurz von
der karte nein hier freunde damit hier
gucken habt so also jetzt haben wir 100
euro und gehen vorüber denn das amüsiert
wie nennt man sowas arisierung es
geschafft hast du da ich hoffe hier spaß
geschäft oder keine ahnung wie viel spaß
es nicht okay
als garten und dann weg
das publikum
druck ist da alex
das war ja mal voll im griff ins klo
erst jetzt schon dass die preise
ich bin mal gespannt ob überhaupt ein
geworden
diese art der gleich gar nicht
bilder
die zweite liga
eigentlich
das tut der muss klar
haye war gut einem jahr
also sind übrigens die 100 mal kleiner
aus
sie liegen alle scheiße
ich habe aus einer verlässlichen quelle
erfahren was die so programmiert sind
dass sie hier ist 30 mal wirklich
richtig zu greifen
was daran jetzt genau stimmt weiß ich
deswegen wollte testen weil ich habe nie
aus
mit aller kraft mit söhnchen griffin
vielleicht ins lernen
ich gehe das nicht mitgehen
das ist ein bisschen
von jahr zu jahr wieder in zwei hälften
wir sind ja schon
[Musik]
frau
auch gewährt
also
er war schon da
so ein rezept von deiner kraft
das machen würde
dieser bietet
dagegen formiert
gestartet bei dem schlechten wetter
ja
nein doch der muss sie dafür
17 stunden
neun auf 17 länder
stocker wird
die gerne zugespielt
so
die einmal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
während sich mit
schrecklich traurig
das ist echt unglaublich dass deswegen
macht das niemals machen
da können aber auch durch
gegenüber sehen sind
ist weiß harting
oder so gut aus
funktioniert es der person
streiche der greift hier leute wer mit
60 euro
nicht so einfach
die ausstellung machen
geht es doch mal
betreibt hier nicht zu
[Musik]
vielleicht noch mehr
ja
wir wollen weiter
1840 gewissen kommentieren dürfen
endlich los
und er will
verträge sind dazu da können sie einfach
2000 und wir sind wir sind sie noch 80
euro die gleise
und jetzt bleibt er wieder nicht zu dem
klima
die man den rest hier noch aus wir haben
eigentlich auch drei credit suisse
das war's
hey
alex wice wir machen da bin
wir machen doppelt
wir haben
doch einfach
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 euro haben wir noch
alles um 1 90 euro ausgegeben alex
so leute wir sind jetzt wieder zurück
bei mir im zimmer also das nicht
wirklich spaß gemacht es war so lustig
auch die leute die ganze zeit kamen und
zugeguckt haben haben uns die aufnahme
studie sprechen sie auch selber ja man
heftig dürfen auf jeden fall ist hat
euch gefallen
checkfelix kanada bis ganz oben der
wiederbestellung verlinkt abonniert auf
jeden fall
wir machen jetzt noch ein paar andere
videos hier die werden auch lustig also
die commerz die woche über ne und was
wir noch sagen wollten es ganz wichtig
also ich habe es ja auch im video schon
öfter gesagt aber diese automaten dann
wirklich manipuliert also das ist
eigentlich wirklich betrug ich gucke
auch mal ob mann ob man vielleicht
irgendwie dagegen vorgehen kann sowohl
stellt euch nicht dahin also das ding
ist um einfach was rausholen müsstet ihr
mindestens zwanzig dreißig euro ausgeben
kommt halt wahrscheinlich auch auf den
automaten an wie die programmiert sind
jetzt des alphabets aber er hat es ja
gesehen dieser greifarm ging wirklich 40
50 60 mal einfach so drauf und dann ganz
normal wieder hoch also dabei gar keine
gar keinen widerstand und plötzlich
zieht er dann zwei stofftiere
gleichzeitig raus und es macht ja keinen
sinn das ganze ding ist einfach gehen
lassen hat mal erzählt dass dann könnt
ihr auch selber machen als ich schon mal
mit der kugel wie es um herauszufinden
und irgendwas findet kölner zu bzw
du kannst ja mal wieder zu machen so was
ja echt ein absoluter 214 dabei raus und
vorher sind eier gehabt und dann fällt
er einfach mal runter das war irgendwann
geht's ohne das war ja und leute was ich
mir auch noch überlegt habe was richtig
weiß wer diese automaten kann man auch
also die kann man nicht offiziell kaufen
aber es gibt leute die verkaufen sich
zum beispiel bei ebay oder so dass ich
mir also einzulegen kostet ungefähr 4
500 euro hier in die wohnung stelle und
dann immer so kälin des veranstalters
wird mit ganz vielen freunden und dann
tut man so ein kassen gegenstand verein
und der den halt wirklich krieg darf ihn
behalten würde darauf beharrt dass man
danach um lahm würde ich richtig feiern
also etwas richtig spaß dran und anzahl
der erste sein der klar korrekt freunde
aber passiert was gutes dann hole ich
mir das so fordere sofort schaltautomat
leute also checkt bei felix vorbei wir
sehen uns abonniere nicht vergessen haut
rein
[Musik]